[Musique]
cette eau Vermont près de la frontière
québécoise que tranquillement le rêve
d'éliminer 3% des gaz à effet de serre
de la planète commencent à se réaliser
en 5 ans la jeune entreprise bêta
technologies a créé ici un des modèles
d'avion les plus avancés
son projet de thèse à l'Université
Harvard un avion qui vole grâce à des
batteries électriques
alia a été conçue pour transporter
l'équivalent de trois palettes cargo de
marchandises ou bien six passagers pour
un ingénieur en fait c'est comme c'est
Noël
dirige l'équipe responsable de
développer les moteurs de l'avion on est
parti d'une page blanche puis on
développe vraiment tout c'est pas un
ajustement une technologie existante
c'est vraiment du départ c'est ce qui
excitant puis en même temps on construit
une compagnie d'aéronautique
bêta a reçu des centaines de millions de
dollars de financement et est
aujourd'hui évalué à plus de 2 milliards
de dollars ça fait partie d'un ensemble
d'entreprises il y a eu mais il y en a
plein d'autres aujourd'hui qui sont de
différentes manières différentes
approches de aborder la question de la
version électrique ce spécialiste en
aéronautique suit de près la course
planétaire vers l'avion écologique
Airbus embraha air les avancées sont
impressionnantes mais les enjeux sont
immenses vu la quantité d'énergie
électrique nécessaire la question
aujourd'hui c'est que on est très limité
en termes de taille en terme de distance
donc et la vitesse le transporter on va
dire une cinquantaine de personnes
traversent l'Atlantique par une par
exemple Montréal Paris il va falloir
avoir plusieurs milliers tonnes de
batterie comme pour les voitures
électriques ce sont les batteries qui
demeurent un grand défi
en attendant Ali accumule les vols
d'essai ce jour-là ils étaient une
douzaine d'employés comme Manon à faire
le point en vue du prochain test on fait
des essais de vol presque à tous les
jours c'est des essais de vols qui nous
donnent
l'opportunité d'avancer rapidement dans
notre développement
la législation est pas encore adaptée
donc je vois pas comment d'ici deux
trois ans peut être changer pour pour
permettre à ces engins là de de déplacer
le 7 8 9 10 personnes
un cours et moyen terme ce sont
toutefois des marchandises que
l'entreprise souhaite transporter un
secteur moins réglementé
a d'ailleurs signé un contrat avec la
compagnie de transport youpi yes qui
espère acheter jusqu'à 150 appareils
[Musique]
beta est aussi présente à Montréal pour
profiter de l'expérience régionale en
aérospatiale et s'apprête à youvrir un
laboratoire en ingénierie
moi je pense que dans cinq ans les gens
vont voir des avions électriques livrer
du cargo ou faire livrer même des
passagers peut-être
puis dans 15 ans il va avoir beaucoup
beaucoup moins de petits avions avec des
moteurs à combustion
électrique hybride et même à hydrogène à
petit pas cette nouvelle génération
d'avions plus vert devient réalité
[Musique]